- Yeah, the public thought
Kennedy looked great.
Under the lights in those days,
a blue shirt really is
better than a white shirt.
It helps if you speak
in complete sentences
and look at the cameras.
(audience laughing)
No question, people reacted to that.
And yes, Nixon looked
like he'd been sleeping
under a highway for a week--
(audience laughing)
But the numbers said, "So what,"
because the trial heats, the horse race,
didn't budge a millimeter.
Between the first and the second one
and between the first and the fourth,
the needle hardly moved at all.
And we also looked into another,
it's an example of something
that gets repeated for 60 years
and people think it's
repeated because it's true,
namely that Nixon was
fantastic on the radio
and Kennedy was fantastic on television
and that's really what happened.
There was absolutely no evidence
to support that contention at all.
There was a survey, an audience survey,
done by Sindlinger's people,
but it wasn't published
until after the election,
and some indication
you have to discount it
because the radio listeners
tended to be more rural by 1960
and thus more conservative.
Nixon was very good in the debates.
Point, counterpoint.
The country was divided.
Change, continuity.
Take some risks for
peace, Cold War strength.
Right down the middle.
We made an analogy in the general election
to a couple of guys on a teeter-totter.
And in the course of those
three or four months,
the thing would move
an inch or two one way
and that's about it,
and the debates need to be
reexamined in that context,
I think, because they are
not the key to the election.